we are hiring at think media and in this
video i'm going to be talking about
the five c's that we look for in think
media leaders and team members and i
also believe if you don't even want to
apply for think media you're going to
love this video because we're going to
be talking about the secret to
accelerating your personal success
how to build a strong reputation in the
marketplace
and essential leadership qualities that
will help every content creator and
entrepreneur
of course if we happen to just be
meeting my name is sean cannell i'm the
founder of think media 10 years ago i
just started shooting videos in my
bedroom as a college dropout and today
we've grown into a multi-million dollar
media company we have 18 team members
and we are hiring again and i'm going to
be talking a little bit about our vision
and our values and i believe that
whether you're just want to be a fly on
the wall whether you're a leader from
another organization that wants to learn
a little bit about how we do leadership
and what we look for in terms of the
culture and team we're building or
whether you would like to apply all you
have to do is actually go to work with
think dot com to see the current job
openings
and um you can apply and i'll tell you a
little bit more about the specific
positions later you know our mission at
think media is to help 10 000
purpose-driven people create a full-time
living
doing what they love while making a
difference in the world
with youtube and online video but sean
what are some of the things that you
look for these are really the five
c's we look for in all think media
leaders and it's important to say why do
i say leaders
because actually we really have a
leadership culture we believe that
leaders create leaders not more
followers
and we want to build leaders
we want to develop leaders but we also
are looking for leaders we believe
leaders are change makers we're looking
for change agents
and so we speak about and speak to our
team
as leaders and we want to call we
believe the world needs leaders and so
these are five things we look for and
think media leaders even if you're like
well if i applied it for an internship i
might not be a leader yet well first of
all we're going to call that leadership
out of you
but we are looking for leaders and um
number one
is character number one is character and
the five c's number one is character
this is the foundation of all other
virtues you know i'm going to get into
four other c's but if you don't have
character
you've already lost before you started
now listen this isn't some kind of
you know we expect people to be perfect
we're not perfect we got a lot of flaws
but you can imagine on a surface level
it's like
if i can't trust you to not steal money
right it doesn't matter how skilled you
are at anything else
that's kind of a surface level of
character like if you
if i can't trust you to to not be
just trustworthy and speak you know not
gossip and tear down the company from
within
what it doesn't matter if you have the
highest skill set in the world like if
you don't have character
then you already lost
so character is the foundation of all
other virtues and we've also
specifically noticed that in influencer
culture and youtube culture is one of
the biggest missing elements in a lot of
people's lives for example you know
charisma and popularity
without character will eventually lead
to a crash we
recognize and and it's kind of the less
talked about see
that we're looking for people of
character so what does that mean it
means your word is your bond that if you
say you're gonna do something you do it
um that means you take extreme ownership
so we're trying to build a culture great
book by the way by jocko willink
instead of you know if something goes
wrong do you blame others or do you take
responsibility what was their fault well
leaders actually take extreme ownership
it's characters having a whatever it
takes attitude
oh i don't know it's so hard i don't
know if i'm gonna be able to get it done
as opposed to like whatever it takes
like hey like i don't know it's gonna be
challenging i don't know if i can solve
the problem but i'm gonna do whatever it
takes
character is you're trustworthy
character is we're looking for people
who if they're gonna represent think
media they have a reputation of being
loyal on time and hard-working
character is having a strong work ethic
a strong work ethic isn't as evidence of
character
laziness is not an attribute of
character flakiness is not an attribute
of strong character
so having a strong work ethic means
there's follow through
and that actually actions are bigger
than words you know what's funny about
hiring is people can interview well
fill out an application talk about all
their accolades
it's one thing to talk big and you got
to describe by the way please do that
please describe
these details about you
but actions you know are louder than
words right anybody could talk big it's
a whole nother thing to actually show up
and follow through now this one's
important to me character also means a
good attitude you know we believe
attitude's a choice and and having a
good attitude attitude uh affects
everybody else attitude is contagious a
negative attitude man someone walks into
the room and the whole room just just
sucks the energy it's like wow the
energy just left the room and just the
whole atmosphere shifted when the bad
attitude showed up in the room on the
flip side a good attitude and and
walking in just joy now get this is not
it's not false positivity we're we're a
family at think media so we like to walk
through people we would like to walk
with people when they are going through
hard times and where they're carrying
something heavy
but a lot of things
smiling is a choice
having a good attitude is a choice
character means being self-motivated
and character also means common sense it
means you know like being just being
diligent with the details and having the
ability to follow instructions number
two chemistry
second to character which is the
foundation would just be
are you
a good fit for the think media culture
now this isn't a right or wrong answer
in terms of i'm not saying i think media
culture
is the only culture obviously there's a
lot of places you could work or a lot of
things you could do but what's important
to us
is that
amazing people in this world that are
remarkable people might not be a very
good fit at think media or they won't be
a good fit they're incredible
it's uh it's us it's not them it's us
like you know but so what we're looking
for is those that are a good fit for the
think media culture
you know talking to other leaders
you you want to make sure you have the
right chemistry it's we even ask can we
go on a road trip with this person
because we do stuff together so it's
like would we also want to hang out with
this person can we vibe with this person
your vibe attracts your tribe and so
somebody they might have the greatest
skills in the world and the greatest
character but like the chemistry is not
quite right
in our case
then that would not be
then chemistry really matters and it's
the question of are you a good fit for
the think media culture so what is the
thick media culture well we work hard
and we play hard
so we really have an ethic of doing the
hard thing first there's seasons where
you could talk to the think team like
man it's there's some intense seasons
but think also backs its word up where
there's also
uh there's also margin there's also you
know time for of course valuing family
and time off and rest it's a rest run
culture
um but also uh and there's team
celebrations and there's things like
that so we're gonna work hard but we're
also gonna play hard i'm good with
people we we work hard and we have fun
in the process and so the ability to
just have fun we're serious we know when
to like get really serious and focused
but we also want to keep an atmosphere
of having fun and celebration um in our
culture this is a big one
positive and encouraging
our culture at think media is we speak
life
we we speak life into others we
encourage others we like to build each
other team members up
we don't you know of course there's some
joking and whatnot but i think that at
some times you know you could get into a
toxic environment with a lot of cynicism
or just a lot of jokes at others expense
and generally we want to lean towards
building others up speaking life into
others
this is also not a delusional culture we
identify the problem with blunt sober
reality will identify problems but then
we approach them with optimism
so we identify the problem but we choose
to see and pursue possibilities in think
media culture it's like hey sean we got
a problem i go great
give me three possible solutions like we
are not afraid of addressing problems i
want all the problems brought to us or
solved but but it's not just we don't
magnify the problem build a campfire
around the problem complain about the
problem complaining is not a strategy we
are positive and encouraging and and we
see possibilities we're a grateful
culture grateful for each other grateful
for the gift of life grateful that we
get to do this grateful for we just we
live in gratitude we we live we believe
in an abund that we're living in
abundance by the way
even when resources are scarce we
believe we're living in abundance even
when pressure is high we have an
abundant mentality we're grateful humble
that the more influence we get we don't
want it to go to our head the more
influence we get we we don't lord over
people by the way
leaders at think media that because
we're leaders we don't positionally use
that to
uh be a jerk or or to uh have a big ego
humility is an aspect of our culture
okay number three
and hit like wherever you're if you
happen to be watching this on youtube if
you're on the audio podcast
um
leave a review if you resonate with some
of these values i appreciate you
number three is competency and these are
in order so first you know character is
the foundation of all other virtues if
you don't have that and you can't be
trusted well the next four don't matter
chemistry is now hey do you fit here and
so it's like okay if there's
compatibility in chemistry at think the
next question is competency and i want
you to hear that what this one means is
are you able to get the job done
in our opinion if you've got character
as i described it you're probably great
to join the think team because we want
to build a team of of leaders that
are addicted to learning and willing to
learn and grow because there's a lot of
new skill sets like we've had people
join the team they didn't know how to do
digital marketing or paid ads now they
do they didn't know how to write emails
uh and and copywriting and now they do
like they've learned those skills but
they were they had the character they
had the chemistry and they developed the
competency but
confidence competency means you know are
you able to get the job done
and we're kind of talking about two
areas here on the one hand we have
interns that we want to hire so
you there's that side of things if you
go to work with think.com to apply then
there's actually the full-time positions
that are open right now and so in this
case some of the questions we're asking
is what have you built
another way to put that is like when
have you done this before
you know we're hiring for some
assistance and it'd be like have you
helped
you know save the person you've helped
you've you've been a personal assistant
before
and you've
dynamically optimized the person you are
working with travel schedule you've
helped them save time go faster you've
helped them uh
really
10x their relationship mapping
really you know send gifts to the people
they care about take things off their
plate like what have you have you done
it before so depending on what it is
like another way to put it is if you
apply to be a a content creator as an
intern
um show us your youtube channel like
even if it's 300 subscribers
you've actually built something before
here's another way to put it show me
your portfolio like if you're going to
apply to be a graphic designer and you
don't have a portfolio of any of your
graphics
if you say i'd love to intern and bring
my social media skills show me the
instagram accounts you've grown
you don't have to have grown it to a
hundred thousand but like let's see
what you've done here's another way to
put it
have you been successful twice
see we have this high ethic at thick
media to where the most the biggest
predictor that you'll be successful
tomorrow is that you've been successful
today number four is capacity
are you able to work fast and handle
pressure
here's an additional c to just
competency because here's what i've
learned
that in my opinion just does it work
in a 2021 culture and what i mean is
this
we're in we are in an era where speed
matters
so if you go back 10 or 20 years
just being able to get the job done was
maybe good enough
but i really believe we're in a time
where you have to be able to get the job
done fast
so
speed matters so the question is not
only can you do it can you do it quickly
can you do it repeatedly and can you
keep doing it over time
i hope you're also getting value if this
is just like if you develop these skill
sets it's going to help you as an
independent content creator it's going
to help you at your current job this is
going to help prepare you for your next
opportunity so it's one thing competency
is like can you do it like for sure you
could do it you could do it excellently
okay cool but also can you do it quickly
because we don't have a whole week to
get one thumbnail done you know what i
mean like we need three thumbnail
variations on three videos today we
gotta work fast
and then though it's not just well every
once in a while you can do whatever it
is your role is well but can you not
just do it can you also do it fast but
can you also continue to show up in that
area and do it repeatedly which speaks
to
grit and and consistency
um it goes back to the question and
competency of like have you been
successful twice
a lot of us could get lucky
right we've we've done something one
time and so we we kind of got lucky or
like we had a couple hits
but it's one thing to be able to
consistently deliver
on that unique area that we are adding
to the overall team and then can you do
it over time now i know some of these
things might be kind of a challenge to
think about
but can you do it over time it's like
it's not just you you've been able to be
consistent for three months or you've
been able to to be in be in a fast-paced
work environment and sometimes a of
environment of pressure and what do i
mean by that
right now we post about 10 videos a week
on think media
i mean customer service the amount of of
customers we have is a lot like amount
of emails or inbound so it doesn't you
know our event
uh that's coming up soon is gonna be 600
people with lots of guest speakers with
lots of logistics so it's just and then
and everything's growing and so there's
gonna be more customers and even more
youtube channels that we start and more
content creators or rather think
personalities that that grow on the team
so there's just a lot of different
moving parts when you think about the
internship there's a lot to be involved
in but but capacity-wise matters at
think media and number five is is
courage number five is courage
and let me ask you a question are you
ready
to step out on a bold adventure
see when it comes to think media seas of
leadership
and of our team members
we really believe we're on a bold
adventure and it's been wild it's been a
wild ride
and and we believe courage is a huge
attribute
again if you feel like this list of
attributes is a little heavy but you're
like man
but i aspire to that i want to do that i
encourage you to apply because that'd be
a courageous bold move
don't put us at think media on pedestals
don't
you
the accolades
and the results are real
but we are a product
i am heather taurus's omar al taquarius
we're a product
of god's grace
of a commitment to growth
of a commitment to continuous learning
of a commitment to leadership and
leveling up and getting one percent
better every day
and we've been on that journey some of
us and myself as the founder for over a
decade
and so
if you say man
you know where could you be
three years from now where could you be
being immersed in a culture like think
media's
in a leadership personal development
culture and then by the way
our vision and my hope is is that we
people join the team
and that they build for life that
they're here for life and help us build
but we also don't have any kind of weird
toxic energy about
worrying if you come and you have a
vision to be a part of think for a few
years and and you see that as an
opportunity to grow and develop and then
you want to launch out
we are not
trying to just
be a company that has focus on
self-preservation
we are a company that is focused on
sending leaders
we hope to build a culture so good that
people don't want to leave but we also
think the world is in so much need
that we want to send leaders
from think media that are maybe here for
three years five years ten years
so are you ready to step out on a bold
adventure one of the reasons why think
media is thriving is because the think
media team is courageous
and what does that mean it means they
have strength in the face of pain or
grief
are our lives perfect
frick no you know what i mean like
have we been through health challenges
relationship drama with each other you
know
challenges in with family members the
death of family members of some of our
team members financial setbacks drama
you know in in our local states or
communities
the emotional ups and downs of life
pain
and grief
you bet we have
we have we've been through all kinds of
crazy stuff but courage
is the commitment
to persevere
through the ups and downs of life if
you've been following us and you
resonate with with the think media
podcast or think media channel then
consider joining us on this bold
adventure and maybe taking a risk and
even making a sacrifice financially or
time
um and if you feel it
then let's step out
my name is sean cannell and i just want
to say i respect you especially for
listening this long to content like this
um and uh obviously this is some of the
deep work right this is this is
essential qualities of great leaders and
i also want to encourage you hey whether
you apply and get accepted or not or
whether you don't even want to apply and
you want to take some of this
information back to your team or just
even for the team you're building
whatever
um
the world needs leaders right now
the world needs
people of character
and people of competency and people of
courage
to solve major problems
the world needs
freedom fighters and truth bearers
raising their voice in the midst of
evil agendas and in the midst of
misinformation in the midst of
a lot of low ethic and low moral
content that is pulling people down and
that is
harming a lot of lives
if you've got a conviction for putting
bit into the world and really making an
impact please continue to step out
continue to build your character
continue to persevere and and hopefully
the think media story is inspiring to
you um a lot of people
underestimate what they can accomplish
in one year
because think media 2010 to 2011 was not
very it's not a lot was accomplished
then
a lot of people overestimate what they
can accomplish in one year but they
underestimate what they can accomplish
in 10. and now looking back 11 years
since the first video was uploaded on
think media it's crazy
the emails we're getting the stories
that are coming our way the financial
resources that have been produced that
we're able to support organizations like
compassion international and sponsor 50
kids
in terms of education and food in
developing nations where we are able to
um take care of our team and continue to
try to build a healthier culture here
dude what do i even know i'm trying to
learn how to be a ceo friend i'm trying
to figure out
even even building these things out this
has been my journey i'm trying to just
pass along the building blocks i've
personally gone through
um
and
and we're seeing great things happen to
think and it'll be incredible
um if you feel like you'd want to be a
part of this journey then go to work
with think.com and apply
you